für seine landsleute inszeniert er sich
gerne als stark und männlich und auch
gegenüber dem ausland lässt er keine
zweifel daran dass er russland zu alter
stärke zurückführen will
wladimir putin bestimmt seit der
jahrtausendwende die geschicke russlands
seine macht will er in absehbarer zeit
nicht abgeben
in russland gibt es seit jahrhunderten
das konzept des vaters der nation
es gibt eine sehnsucht nach einem vater
der nation und putin füllt diese rolle
aus im paternalistischen gesellschaften
scheuen die menschen eigene
entscheidungen sie lassen lieber andere
die entscheidungen fällen und putin
handelt russlands militärisches
eingreifen in der ukraine oder seine
schützende hand über den syrischen
machthaber baschar al-assad haben tiefe
gräben zu westlichen staaten aufgerissen
kritiker werfen ihnen die aushöhlung der
demokratie in russland vor
bei 80 prozent der russen ist der kreml
chef dagegen so populär wie nie die die
ihn nicht mögen sind doch nur neidisch
aufnehmen weil sie die wirtschaft und
ein so großes land nicht so gut hören
kann in mrs
bei der präsidentschaftswahl am sonntag
streng putin sein viertes mandat an
wer ihm politisch gefährlich werden
könnte wie sein wichtigster kritiker
alexej nawalny den lässt putin durch die
justiz kaltstellen
seine sieben herausforderer jedenfalls
sind nicht mehr als zählkandidaten